we need more time that is the message
that several countries are bringing to
an emergency g7 meeting today as western
allies struggle to evacuate people from
afghanistan germany france and the uk
are all pushing the u.s for an extension
to its august 31st departure deadline
but the taliban say they have just seven
days to leave kabul airport where
thousands of afghans are still waiting
to escape
these sisters are preparing to leave
kabul airport on a flight to the uk
they are traveling with their father
who is seeking refuge from the taliban
and do you think the taliban would have
killed you
yes
yes
[Music]
this was like everybody was scared
that's what they're going to do
and the first time they're telling the
people that we're going to do nothing
for everybody
but nobody knows
[Music]
the family was lucky to escape when they
could
international military personnel are
struggling to complete evacuations
before the deadline of august 31st when
remaining u.s troops are supposed to
leave afghanistan
we know
and are linked very closely with central
command on potential operations to close
out the mission by the 31st that was the
direction
given by the president and we're
committed to do that and my commitment
is ensure that airlift is never the
constraint
to execute those operations we are
pushing the limits uh to do everything
we can
to get every single evacuee
out of kabul
the evacuations are set to be a key
topic of discussion at a special g7
meeting on afghanistan on tuesday
the uk and the european union have
called on the u.s to delay its
withdrawal
and germany is pushing for the airport
to remain open after the u.s army leaves
we are in talks with the us and turkey
in order to keep kabul airport
operational to make civilian evacuations
possible
the taliban have warned that any delay
in the international exit would be met
with unspecified consequences
president biden
uh announced
this agreement that until uh 31st of
august they would withdraw all their
military forces
so if they extend it that means they are
extending occupation
for tens of thousands of people in
afghanistan fear of militant rule is
driving them to try to get out
but with very little time left to
evacuate it seems the u.s will need to
make a deal with the taliban to ensure
they can leave
for more let's cross straight now to
journalist franz marti in kabul france
u.s president joe biden is set to decide
within the next 24 hours whether to
extend this timeline for withdrawal has
this cr increased the sense of
desperation in kabul especially among
afghans who are wanting to leave
i don't think it had that much of a
significant impact it might have
increased the desperation a bit but the
desperation was already like sky high
during the the past few days so already
during the past few days um the feeling
was like time is running out if i don't
get out now uh i can't anymore um and
this was also what this panic this this
feeling of desperation was also what
like contributed to the chaos at airport
people going there not having the right
documentation and just like hoping to
get somehow on a plane or they're going
there with the right things
but not managing to get in despite
having done everything correctly
so yeah the situation was already dire
before uh and couldn't get much worse
now the taliban are warning of
consequences if biden does extend the
withdrawal uh deadline which would be
one week from today what
could the taliban possibly do if the ted
lie if the deadline does get extended
i mean the taliban control kabul there's
only a small contingent um at campbell
airport of course they could like tech
in theory uh take drastical measures uh
attacking trying to shot the american
operation down however it's very
important to note that one has to
differentiate between taliban rhetoric
and taliban actions for example
this spring the taliban in their
propaganda also were very adamant that
u.s troops has to be out have to be out
by 1st of may a date that was
conditionally set in the u.s taliban
agreement and also there they have
implied that the overstay would crea
would like be followed by consequences
but then the real politic was this uh
the taliban decided it's not a good idea
to to shoot at the us if they're indeed
on their way out and then they kind of
did nothing um and uh as at least they
didn't attack u.s forces and um
something similar could happen now uh
this is speculation though
now tens of thousands of people have of
course been evacuated from uh the afghan
capital but obviously the pressure is on
now to get more people out you've said
that the desperation the levels of
desperation can't really get much worse
how are things at and around the airport
right now
i have been in touch with someone who
has conducted evacuation like yesterday
night
um and he today in the morning told me
that it is still like celtic scenes
tragic scenes
uh people breaking down
people handing their babies over to two
forces to somehow get them in um so like
really still heartbreaking scenes uh
still a lot of people who desperately
try to get out um in this regard i think
it is important though to also say that
inside the city uh the situation is
relatively calm that doesn't mean that
like people are happy or everything is
fine it just means that like a much
larger number than the tenth of thousand
at the airport um
stay here whether deliberately or if
they kind of
have resigned to the fact that they have
no reasonable way out and they stay
behind and try to sort out their life
now as quietly as calmly as possible
france marty thank you for your
reporting from kabul
now many at-risk afghans are still
waiting to be evacuated from kabul
airport they're mainly interpreters or
contractors who worked for u.s german or
other nato forces but some have already
made it out in our next report we meet
two people who worked for the german
army in mazaya sharif they and their
families traveled to germany last month
at their own expense dw's wilbiah
vasaman picks up their story from here
these two men are too scared to show
their faces
they're not afraid for their own safety
but that of their loved ones in
afghanistan
we will call them sultan and nabi for
security reasons
they worked for the bundeswehr in the
northern city of mazari sharif
now the only contact they have with
their native country is by phone
my family is in
in deep danger right now so i'm really
concerned about them about their life
about their everything
because
as the taliban find them
or the taliban know that i have worked
with
internationals
for many many years and support them
then they will
of course find him and seize them as
hostages
in an interview with dw the two men
warned that the taliban cannot be
trusted
everyone knows taliban and taliban is
not
like they are not really in
in normal
people they are just
they're just killing people like
like butchers and we cannot believe them
the men along with their wives and
children are now safe at this refugee
shelter in berlin
but their parents siblings and friends
have not received visas
i hope this and this is kind of a
responsibility for the countries that we
work for
they should bring all our families that
they are left behind in afghanistan
because taliban will kill them all
the fact that they made it to germany is
little consolation to them given the
current situation
of course i'm here
right now safe
but my mind is not safe my heart is not
safe so everybody's in there so if my
family is there then
it means that i'm there so they they are
in deep danger right now
they talk to their relatives in
afghanistan every day nothing has
happened to anyone so far and they can
only hope that it stays that way
now as thousands tried to flee
afghanistan there are fears the taliban
could roll back the freedoms and rights
of afghan women and girls in particular
who remain behind under previous taliban
rule women were not allowed to work in
jobs that put them in contact with men
but recent images of a female news
anchor interviewing a taliban spokesman
live on air suggests the group might be
pushing a more moderate image to the
outside world and some girls have
reportedly returned to school this week
this was also forbidden under the
taliban's previous regime however it's
not clear if this will last
and we're joined now by samira hamidi
amnesty international's campaigner who
has worked extensively to improve
women's rights in afghanistan and she
founded an organization that aims to
empower afghan women and she joins us
now from the sri lankan capital colombo
samira welcome to dw thanks so much for
talking to us can you tell us what is
life like for women and girls in
afghanistan right now
women and girls are extremely concerned
about the future they are
of course what what i'm hearing and what
we are hearing through the news is that
taliban
or
have not yet uh specifically discussed
uh how they will be
allowing women uh to engage uh into to
be included but based on their meetings
and based on their discussions that that
are happening in in the last one week
we see a clear absence of women women
especially women leaders especially
those women who were part of different
processes in afghanistan and that
clearly passes a message that
taliban are not open to women's
engagement and participation
samira there are so many fears obviously
that women are facing at the moment
would you say that with the taliban now
in power
education will women once again be
denied the right to education
absolutely
because
i i just want to reflect on on some of
the districts that taliban
had power or had in their control
during the during uh you know
past governments uh women
women were abundant from from societal
prisons and
no girls schools were open girls were
not allowed to go and study and
that is a a serious matter of concern
that
they have not changed they have not
become moderate uh what they are showing
right now is part of a propaganda that
they just would like to say that we are
open and and we uh we are we will be
allowing women and girls to to be
meaningfully engaged to seek education
but time will show us and and uh
win the trust of of uh people and
afghanistan especially women and girls
who have suffered badly from them
now thousands of afghans have of course
managed to leave the country many with
just the most basic of belongings can
you tell us what future are they facing
this is a this is a very troubling uh
time for for a lot of people who
who have uh
decided to leave afghanistan and and
who have no choice
among them or you know journalists women
activists human rights defenders who are
exposed to the direct uh persecution
for for their human rights work they
have received threats and in warnings in
the past from from the taliban um the
future is very unclear for them honestly
based on what we are hearing from
international community
that they are welcoming
you know these groups of people and
they they have plans for them i really
hope that there will be a there will be
a culture of acceptance for them they
will have opportunities to still work
for afghanistan they will have
opportunities to heal because
what they have gone through and
where they have reached is is very
traumatizing i am talking to some of
them and it is very very traumatizing
samira hamidi amnesty international
south asia campaigner thank you so much
for your time